vous lui diriez quoi aujourd'hui à
Patrick Sabatier s'il était là
85 ça porte malheur déjà Patrick
Sabatier vous reçoit dans le jeu de la
vérité vous appellerez cette émission un
meurtre en direct et ce n'est que 8 ans
plus tard que vous pouvez regarder la
cassette de l'émission et vous dites
j'ai vu une folle qui parle
moi d'abord j'avais pas voulu la faire
ce que j'étais en plein spectacle
mystérieux voyage de Marie-Rose que vous
avez vu et moi j'avais dit ça sert à
rien parce que c'est tellement archi
complet je me vois pas dans une émission
ou des adultes vont me parler donc ils
m'ont dit non ce seront des enfants qui
vont venir vous parler
à ce moment là j'ai douté un peu et
Jean-Jacques m'a dit il n'en est même
pas question Thierry Le Luron qui était
là m'a dit Chantal ils vont te mais
alors te planter ça va être l'horreur et
j'ai dit ok je la fais plus donc j'ai
appelé j'ai dit on la fait plus et
l'avant veille le réalisateur m'a dit
écoute notre amitié tu devrais quand
même la faire ça sera magnifique il y
aura des belles choses on va voir
Jean-Jacques je ne voyais pas
Jean-Jacques il ne veut pas
finalement tout le monde a tellement
c'est moi qui est qui suis allé au
charbon en fin de compte alors j'ai joué
mon spectacle et la veille Jean-Jacques
m'a dit tu vois c'est bien on a toutes
les lignes de journaux mais je peux te
dire qu'à 10h40 il y aura plus de
Chantal Goya
et je me suis retrouvé avec ma robe rose
de marée rose devant dans mon décor avec
l'arbre la forêt et tout ayant joué
l'après-midi à 8h30 le même public
devant moi de 12000 personnes et pas une
question d'enfant et moi chaque fois
j'étais je prenais tout au troisième
degré alors quand est-ce qu'on parle
c'est la chirurgie à la chirurgie
esthétique avec votre tronche d'autres
c'est pas grave on verra un jour et puis
toute manière
ce qui s'est passé c'est que c'est qu'en
fait vous croyez vous adressez aux
enfants en leur faisant des grimaces en
disant je vais mettre les enfants dans
ma poche je vais leur faire des grimaces
et le réalisateur Rémi grand bac lui il
montre pas les les gens ont eu l'idée de
mettre une fausse institutrice
c'est elle qui a tout déclenché c'est
pas avant avant je m'en sortais très
bien ça se passait bien et cette fausse
institutrice quand j'ai demandé de
quelle classe vous êtes elle a jamais pu
me le dire c'était j'ai dit bon alors
allez faut c'est des bidon c'est fini je
suis dans un traquenard alors là
maintenant j'ai dit à sabète j'ai dit à
cette femme bah écoutez vous m'aimez pas
changer de chaîne j'allais pas dire
madame vous êtes je suis une conne et je
vous remercie ça c'est pas possible
devant plus tout mon public puis j'aime
pas dire ça j'en ai même pas question
alors j'ai dit bon ben je pose mon micro
j'ai dit à Patrick moi je suis désolé il
y a Simone Signoret sur la 2 c'est
beaucoup mieux que Chantal Goya je
m'adresse à mon public qui sont les
enfants et je chantais le pain et là
j'ai posé mon micro j'avais tous ces
gosses devant moi qu'on ne montrait
jamais voilà
parce que dans la panique j'ai une
espèce d'attaque de panique de
terroriser et je me suis réfugiée dans
le monde de l'enfance parce que j'étais
mariée rose et l'image elle a été
changée et moi j'ai vu quand je suis
sortie de là j'ai toujours pas compris à
la fin de l'émission parce que tout le
monde était dans la salle à crier
Chantal Chantal et quand je suis sortie
que j'ai vu
ça aide honneur de tous mes techniciens
qui étaient pratiquement en larmes vous
êtes arrivés dans la régie et là vous
vous tombez sur Jean-Jacques debbouivre
mort
tout ça il avait il avait vu il avait
senti c'était quelqu'un qui avait tout
compris bien avant tout le monde et
étant donné qu'il est quand même la
personne qui m'aime le plus et qui était
proche de moi il était malheureux et
finalement on a mis 100 personnes au
chômage et c'est pour ça que moi comme
je suis ça m'a pas cassé moi parce que
moi j'étais vrai vis-à-vis de mon public
quand j'ai fait le lapin et que j'ai dit
changer de changer de chaîne avec
Chantal Goya c'est que vous m'aimez pas
c'était pour sauver tout le public des
petits qui m'aimaient et être proche
d'eux vous pensez qu'il y a une
véritable volonté de nuire derrière
cette histoire Chantal attendez
qui aurait eu envie de vous nuire
moi je pense que enfin j'ai pas encore
la réponse exacte mais je pense que
il y avait une grande jalousie qui
circulait dans enfin les gens étaient
assez jaloux de mon succès et il y a des
gens qui m'adoraient et des gens qui
m'aimaient pas c'est normal aujourd'hui
tout est bien qui finit bien car tu es
culte non mais je vais vous dire une
chose et tu es une histoire pour les
gosses tu es qu'une pour les adultes et
tu es hyper populaire donc ça se termine
bien tu as envie de faire un duo
je vais vous dire Thierry je vais vous
dire ça devait m'arriver cette histoire
et moi je l'ai très bien prise parce que
je me suis dit c'est peut-être très
triste tout ce qui vient de m'arriver
mais c'est un grand bonheur pour moi de
retrouver mes petits-enfants ma famille
enfin mes enfants qui étaient que je
voyais pas beaucoup ma famille mes amis
et d'être auprès du public qui me
réconfortait tous les jours dites-moi
vous lui diriez quoi aujourd'hui à
Patrick Sabatier s'il était là
j'ai jamais vu je sais qu'elle existe
mais qu'elle n'est pas si tu triste ça
je le sais que c'était quelqu'un qui
était payé par la production je suis
toujours demandé comment ça se fait
qu'un journaliste n'a pas été plus loin
dans cette histoire et n'a pas été voir
qui était cette femme qui peut-être est
très malheureuse dans son coin parce
qu'elle en a pris plein la tronche aussi
autant que moi parce qu'elle est pas si
tu triste aujourd'hui tout va bien mais
le lendemain des missions tout allait
aujourd'hui une émission comme le jeu de
la vérité par exemple vous craquez plus
on va voir regardez moi
euh vous pensez pas que votre spectacle
est nul à chier Chantal Goya non j'adore
mon spectacle j'aurais jusqu'au bout
j'aurais jusqu'au bout
vous pensez pas que vous avez tissé les
enfants mais non je les habits pas ou si
c'est votre choix vous pensez pas que
votre âge il faudrait les laisser
tranquille les enfants maintenant il y a
pas d'âge pour faire rêver
vous êtes en durci c'est bien je me suis
plus endurci c'est que j'ai gardé ma
sensibilité mais j'ai un bon paravent
devant
[Musique]
et mettez un pouce bleu